I've gotten more private as I've gotten
older um I think that I think that I'm
an extrovert because I get energy I get
energized from other people um my wife
and my mom think that I am an
extroverted introvert yeah um I don't
know I mean I I I feel like I've
certainly changed as I've gotten older
um being in the public eye as well like
the more you're in the public eye the
less you want to give because you just
feel like everyone just wants a piece of
you and like things like social media
and stuff it just you're constantly
putting yourself out there um and you
know with kids and and other things in
my life I'm like I I don't want to be so
transparent anymore I do miss the days I
remember growing up and going to drama
school and stuff and people used to talk
about the the most wonderful gift for an
actor was to have
anonymity because then people can buy
into any character that you're playing
and these days it seems to have been a
size make shift the other way where it's
like you're doing you know you're in a
show or you're doing a film and they
want you to be on social media all the
time push push push push push but not in
the character in the film but as you and
and you feel like you're giving that
away I feel like yeah you're giving away
like your tricks basically you're giving
away your energy the thing that you
bring to a character um is unique to
what you have inside of you and the more
you give of of yourself I feel like the
less people can make that
differentiation right and but like for
example people have a hard time
if I play an American character um not
cuz my dialect is bad I think but mainly
because they think oh it's weird cuz
you're British and like we're used to
you talking a certain way and I just
can't do that thing it's like for me
that's a frustrating kind of reaction
cuz it's like but I'm an actor so my job
is to embody whoever it is I'm playing
and for you to believe that yeah because
in the old days I mean I'm talking like
early 2000s before cell
phones you if they saw an English actor
playing a role they they don't know if
he's English they don't know if he's
American they don't so there's a mystery
of it all yeah but with social media
it's kind of
uh it's erased that mystery and I mean
all my cards are out on the table I mean
Jesus man everybody's like oh yeah it's
rosenbom oh he's doing an English accent
not very good brother you know so yeah I
I can understand that a lot of people
will say that the um what's the word
like you know the the old school actors
the the old the old um you know the
Harrison Fords the real movie stars St
there aren't many around anymore no do
you agree with that I do actually to a
certain extent and I I the weird thing
is that the Stars the movie stars don't
tend to have an awful lot of range
within their performances apart from a
select few that would be known as
character actors right but like people
like Tom Cruz who I think is still one
of the you know few movie stars out
there now Brad Pit you know they're very
similar when you're going to see Tom
Cruz or Brad P you kind of know what
you're going to get but you don't care
because they're a [__] Star right and
uh and then you get the kind of tear
down from that um and that used to be
that you could play whatever role was
given to you um but now it seems like
people if they know too much about you
they have a real hard time buying into
that range yeah I I guess that could be
a little upsetting